c'est une terrible agression raciste qui
est en train de provoquer un torrent de
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment et bien sûr dans la presse
dans les médias a dit cissé frioui sa
femme et ses enfants ont été agressés
devant chez eux et ont échappé de très
peu au pire laetitia la femme d'adil a
tout filmé et ces images sont d'une
extrême violence
on va tout vous montrer on va être avec
adil et letizia ont vision qui vont tous
nous raconter et c'est vrai que cette
histoire aujourd'hui tout le monde en a
parlé
personne n'a pu rester insensible à ce
qu'ils ont vu à ce qu'on a entendu et ça
on s'est dit tous je pense quand on a vu
ces images c'est pas cette france là
dont on a envie et adil et lætitia
forcément et leurs enfants ils sont
extrêmement choqués par ce qui s'est
passé merci d'être avec nous ils seront
avec nous dans un instant on regarde et
voilà ils sont là voilà voilà
franchement même de voilà de devoir adil
dans cet état c'est ses matches et j'ai
dit j'ai si on a vraiment tous du mal
merci adil et lætitia d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup merci d'être là lors tout
a commencé mercredi 21 avril dernier à
dole chez la famille g dans votre
famille un homme semblait prendre des
photos des enfants dans le jardin et
lætitia commence à filmer regardez je
vous film pouvait laver commente abel
vous avez fils vous avez pris en photo
mais enfants vous avez pris en photo
mais confond monsieur vous non magique
vous venez pas marché comment ça se fait
que vous faites ça rend tout cas david
moyes approche papier à dessin excusez
moi monsieur non seulement ce que vous
faites ici moi c'était normal de faire
ça
ok sur youtube pendant qu'est ce que
vous faites ici à prendre des photos des
enfants et j'ai pas vu plus d'une
cousine
vu comme ça on est adulte enfant te faut
pas vu quand on vous voit de tout à
l'heure alors ça c'est le début vous
allez voir il ya trois vidéos ça donc
c'est le début de l'histoire
qu'est-ce qu'ils aient ce monsieur les
tissages comprend pas à prendre des
photos le coc sais je sais pas plus que
vous mais vous me connaissez mes enfants
demandé à 14h à ce petit bout dans
l'intérêt c'est qui il s'est garé sur
sur le trottoir en face de la banane et
puis il a commencé à prendre des photos
pour en direction de la maison
pourquoi il fait ça vous l'avez des
avancées ou là des abus sociaux n'ont
jamais jamais donc vous vous êtes arrivé
où vous l'avez dit pour comprenait les
photos la tête c'est et agressif ah non
en fait moi je lis certains je les ai vu
qui prenait des photos en direction de
la maison j'ai été voir mon mari qui
était dans le salon et puis je lui dis
bah écoute ya un gars bizarre quand des
photos vers la maison il ya les enfants
qui sont dehors sur la terrasse c'est
lisa tu lui dis est ce que tu peux les
regarder
et puis ensuite il est sorti et puis il
a regardé le monsieur derrière la panne
sèche et puis il lui a fait des défis ou
pour voir s'ils y regardaient vient vers
nous et qui bon sur la réagit il appuyé
il est après il a consacré après là il
est venu direct vers mon mari puis
d'insulter tout de suite eh bien c'était
votre mari doit dit quoi ben je sais pas
c'est moi je n'ai pas entendu parce que
j'étais dans la cuisine
en fait si j'osais ce qu'il en fait bon
alors mais dans l'akwa ibom
oui ma famille était dans la cuisine en
train de faire son travail
moi j'étais allongé dans sa vie les
enfants y jouer dans la féroce et
aimante en mai la regarder dans le but
d'y traiter dans la terrasse fois un
monsieur qui se garent conservant n'a
pas laissé la fois c'est un coin
interdit de se garer donc d'accord et il
m'a dit qu'il première idée de traverser
la route dont 3,9 en terrasse il a pris
des photos
il m'a des débuts sport c'est bizarre
c'est un monsieur besson et on voit moi
je sors de mon jardin
je regarde oui les palissades et en vue
de l'autre la pluie voyez on est en
cours j'ai des cachets faire un derrière
orange qui fait qu'on n'accuse pas pour
rien quoi comme une nation vous avez
voulu être sûr de ce qu'il faisait alors
on va voir on va voir la deuxième vidéo
parce que donc vous regardez cet homme
derrière la palissade
vous dites que si ce parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui n'ont jamais vu en plus
donc c'est vrai qu'on se dit qu'est ce
qu'il fait là il prend des photos des
enfants
alors comme vous l'a dit un homme voilà
déjà huit cds associés c'est pas normal
adil va être sûr voilà que c'est bien
quelqu'un qui prend des photos pour ne
pas voilà incriminé ou voilà aller
parler à quelqu'un qui n'a rien à voir
vitaly était juste là donc il essaie
d'être bien sûr que cet homme prend des
photos de ses enfants dans le jardin
vous allez voir la deuxième vidéo c'est
là que ça commence à s'envenimer
on passe à la dernière partie d'émission
regardez c'est la situation va dégénérer
cet homme va commencer à proférer des
menaces et des insultes racistes regarde
oui attendent a dit non c'est vous
qu'êtes vous on sort pas une arme
monsieur dinars monsieur déjà ces
principes ne vous inquiétez pas
koné 28 e c'est pas grave a dit alors là
on voit que la tension a dit qu'est ce
que vous lui avez dit vous quand vous
êtes sorti parce qu'on sent que voilà
vous voulez un petit peu voilà vous
allez voir c'est normal forcément vous
essayer de le faire bouger qu'est ce qui
vous a dit je vais l'aider
expo vous n'avez plus entre dole et est
comme ça vous pas été vains en fait ils
l'avaient l'appareil-photo formulées
dans sa main avec nous pour nous mettre
sur le gema recalons je me rappelle
comme ça et là pour ça il m'a donné un
coût de 170 bonjour mr il est aidé
permet il m'a tapé des pieds a fait
marcher vers la roche sur yon vers le
coffre et la banque va pas rien alizadeh
marché se cherche
c'est pour ça qu'il me disait rien le
croisement pour des mots
alors qu'est ce qui vous a dit dans un
instant parce qu'on va voir que ce
moment et la fin de cette terrible
agression loeb remonte en voiture par et
va revenir pour essayer de faucher toute
la famille je vous le dis les images
sont très violents regardez
je les données en fait que j'ai appelé
les flics la tête chauve à se reprocher
cela livre il a pris en photo les
enfants et tous
[Musique]
voilà alors les images sont terribles un
don qui revient sur les lieux et là il
va foncer sur vous adil la voiture vous
foncez de vous va foncer vous foncer
dessus
qu'est ce qui vous a dit comme insultes
avant et issa qu'est ce qui vous a dit
quand est-ce qu'il a proférées comme
insultes avant sa vie qu tu vas passer
sous le capot avec 1 500 classes on voit
la vidéo et qui fait halte et bien sûr
donc là là vous voyez qui foncent sur
votre mari vous le voyez revenir à quel
moment vous comprenez qu'il va vraiment
foncer sur votre mac ça quand je la vois
mais il est assez incroyable ça devait
être un moment terrible
vous avez là haut en fait c'est la cour
je suis là pour couper un poste fixe et
sert très mal et où le rapport à la
concurrence écumé les bras et fait 200 m
j'aimerais me révéler ses terres face au
15e tour et après revient mais moi je
vis je suis pas en danger
[Musique]
nécessaire pour le vélo qui est dans
notre empreinte de volontaires pour
identité n'a pas aidé la cause qu'il a
accès aux origines rembourser autrement
et m'a laissé autant jce de tournus
mâcon pour moi est le mot que j'ai pour
ma thèse c'est vrai j'ai décidé mais
pourquoi tu dis ça vous arrive
j'avais cru un moment quant à dylan et
vous allez perdre a dit la ville une
voiture qui fonce dessus
cette usine en fait un moment que je
vois le logo de renault
tremper sa part très vite et j'ai dis
donc pas de chansons dans voiture des
loyers et au soir tu fais frictions et
plus tu mens sur le capot de la voiture
et avec la pédagogie des mutations le
capot il est retourné vers le capot
dernière passer le temps et dans les
comptages et les réflexions d'abord
parce que là j'ai dit observer une
pamiers qui la cristal arena pas l'idée
d'y penser qu'il axerait en même temps
j'étais jeune qui a des centres de
lavage aux pays-bas à nouveau ils
restent sur le bord de la voiture après
un nul hier l'accès des pauvres à
l'arrière et leur jeu j'ai appris avec
lui était sur le bateau et j'ai chanté
dans mon jardin magique et de sinay mes
pieds enlève qui matin dans le var déjà
père et de ma mère j'ai fini par me
répond village se montrer en quoi il
convient aussi danser avec ma maman j'ai
fondé sera pas régi par une délégation
doit j'ai dit alors l'agresseur vous le
dis il est âgé de 72 ans il est
finalement accusé de violences
volontaires avec arme et un jour raciste
sera jugée famille lui sa version c'est
l'agresseur explique qu'il a seulement
voulu vous frôlez et a perdu le
troll suite à un déplacement non mais
franchement ford entend des conneries
pareilles
non mais franchement vraiment il faut on
espère qui sera jugée qui sera dit
attention c'est tuer il avoue lui
permettra de révéler ce qui est très
étonnant c'est qu'il n'a été placée que
sous contrôle judiciaire alors avec
interdiction d'approcher la maison m
mais c'est fou un temps parce qu il peut
et les lorientais de recommencer mais
heureusement cad il a eu un bon réflexe
mais nous tuer mais ils voulaient tuer
bah oui je trouve que le fait de ne pas
l'emprisonner excusez moi mais c'est un
voeu comprend pas franchement je suis
dit je comprends pas je sais pas ce
qu'on pense des téléspectateurs moi je
trouve ça fou cézeaux leonardo meurt on
entend des histoires folles
tous les jours c'est incroyable on a
l'impression que l'on peut tout faire
moi perdre à montier oui et puis surtout
on peut s'interroger parce qu'au delà
des 1 sus des insultes racistes qui
prennent en photo des enfants ça veut
dire quoi est-ce qu'il avait l'intention
de kidnapper ou est-ce qu'il avait
encore sur trois intentions encore pire
j'ose même pas le dire voyez donc c'est
très choquant et j'espère que ce
monsieur va payer très cher et très cher
oui j'aurais dit vous n'avez pas eu
accès à son téléphone vous savez pas
finalement ce qu'il y avait comme comme
photos ou films de vos enfants
non c'est un appareil photo
professionnel un froid pareil comme lé
journal d'accord et un homme de 72 ans
très bien en tout cas on espère qu'on va
voir vite des nouvelles de cette affaire
est franchement l'oreille du temps à
perdre
il aurait dû être incarcéré l'aération
bolide
merci en tout cas adil est l'initiateur
est avec nous je souhaite arriver il a
été monté en gare à partir de là voilà
c'est notre faim c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi excusez nous mais
je suis comme vous je suis atterré par s
c'est en tout cas on espère que ça va
aller mieux pour adil vraiment vous fait
de gros bisous et je sais que vous avez
été très choqué le sport aux enfants les
enfants mais si vous avez besoin de
quelque chose n'hésitez pas à appeler
notre production qui
les cons quand vous êtes sur quelque
chose on sera là bien entendu voilà
merci laetitia